[MUSIC PLAYING]
CASEY WHITELAW: So good evening.
And I wanted to say first,
thank you all for being here.
I know that all of you
have somewhere else
that you could be tonight.
So thank you for making
the choice to come here
and the effort to come here
and be part of this community.
And that's what tonight
is all about, right?
It's a community.
It's for all of you to be
part of Women Techmakers,
and more broadly the
community of women in tech.
So why am I standing up here?
It's certainly not
for me to tell you
my story of being
a woman in tech.
But that's also
part of the point.
It's because it's a problem.
It's something that
I care about very
deeply that I'd like to see
better representation of women
in technology.
And I think that it's
important that it's not just
women's voices that we hear, and
it's not just a women's problem
to increase the representation
of women in technology.
And so I thought I would
share some of my thoughts
on diversity, and
specifically, on inclusion.
So last year, I went
to Grace Hopper.
Who knows about Grace Hopper?
Great.
This is the Grace
Hopper Celebration
of Women in Computing.
It's a conference that
they call a celebration.
And I love it.
It changes the mood immediately
when it's a celebration.
People who've been
there, you know
there's a lot more
smiles than you
would expect to see
at something that
would be called a conference.
And for me, as a manager--
so as Marilyn mentioned,
I'm a manager here
at Google-- it
was filled with really
interesting information
essentially about
supporting women
in their careers in technology.
And at a really
high level, it was
about thinking
outside of the box
rather than there being
one kind of engineer.
You might break that
box down and think
there's male engineers
and female engineers.
And surprise,
surprise, there might
be some differences
between these groups
that you might want
to take into account.
And it was about all the
different aspects of a career,
from hiring, recruiting,
interviewing, things like that,
supporting women
in their careers,
looking for leadership
opportunities
and how to promote women
leaders in tech companies.
But when I actually got down to
thinking about the content that
was being presented, the
advice that was being given,
almost none of it was
actually specific to women.
All of it really,
or almost all of it,
was about treating
people as individuals.
Like I said, instead of there
being one box for engineers,
for example, and
splitting into two boxes,
it was really about treating
people as the individuals
that they are and
realizing that everybody
has a different set of needs
that you need to support.
A good example of that
might be recruiting.
So Google, famously,
and many tech companies
do technical interviews, right,
where you get up in a room
and you're asked some
technical questions.
And usually,
traditionally, these
have been done on a white board.
Right?
So at some point
during the interview,
you'll end up writing
on a white board.
You'll write some code on a
white board, which, by the way,
is not what we spend our
time doing at Google.
Right?
This is not the job that
you're being hired to do.
We don't stand around all day
writing code on a white board.
We write code on computers
sitting down or standing up
if you have a standing
desk, writing at a computer.
And it turns out
that many people--
this may come as a huge shock
to you-- many people perform
better if you ask them to write
code on a computer the way
that they're used to doing all
the time rather than saying,
hey, guess what?
Stand up here and write
code on a white board.
And it turns out
the reason that we
were talking about this at
Grace Hopper is that that's
particularly true for women.
So it was something that
they were all pointing out
in terms of making sure that
your hiring processes work well
for women.
But actually, more
generally than that,
it doesn't mean
that all of a sudden
you ask men to stand up
and write at a white board
and you ask women to
sit down and write
at a desk with a computer.
It's about having the option so
that everybody can demonstrate
their skills in the right way.
And that goes for everybody.
And I've talked to
plenty of men as well
who would much
prefer to be writing
their code on a computer rather
than writing at a white board.
And so this is getting to
this point of inclusion.
Right?
So essentially,
for me, inclusion
is about creating an
environment where people
can be themselves, express
themselves as an individual,
and be the best
that they can be.
And that's something
that I wanted
to talk to you a little
bit about tonight.
So again, you might be
thinking, why am I here.
I'm a white man in tech.
What could I possibly have
to say about inclusion?
What story do I have?
And so, actually, I've
spent a fair bit of my life
in places where I haven't
been in the majority.
And the story I want to tell
you tonight is from 20 years ago
when I was living in Japan.
So I was just out of school.
I was on an exchange
student program in Japan.
And so I was living
with a Japanese family.
And I spoke a little bit
of Japanese when I first
got there, but almost nothing.
And the family that I was living
with was not in a big city.
They were in a tiny village
literally surrounded
by rice fields in quite
a remote part of Japan.
And this meant
that I was not only
the only foreigner
in my village.
I was the only non-ethnically
Japanese person in probably
at least 10 kilometers
around where I was living.
And it meant that everybody that
I met, everybody that saw me,
knew immediately who I was.
And actually, they
didn't know who I was.
Right?
They knew what I. I
was the foreigner.
I was the gaijin.
Who's heard the word
"gaijin" before?
Yeah, so gaijin, it
just means foreigner.
It's an abbreviation.
The real word is a gaikokujin.
And it's not necessarily
a bad word in itself.
But it depends how
it's being used,
and certainly depends on
how you're hearing it.
All I knew is that
all of a sudden,
that was a word
that I heard a lot,
like I literally
couldn't walk down
the street without
hearing this word at least
a couple of times.
Not every single time, but
every time I would go out,
somebody who maybe had never
walked past a gaijin before,
would see me and
then would start
talking to their
friend about the fact
that they just saw a gaijin.
And I knew for sure
that every time I
heard that word that it was me
that they were talking about.
It was not a random coincidence
that they were using this word.
It was definitely 100% me.
And the thing that
this made me feel--
I mean, it might be
something that many of you
have felt too-- is just
different, like immediately,
obviously, completely different.
And it was a difference that
was pointed out to me every time
I heard a word like that.
And at first, I thought
it was my problem,
like there was something
wrong with me because of this,
something wrong that
I was doing that was
making me feel this way.
And there were definitely things
that I could do to improve.
And so I thought I'm going
to really learn Japanese
as well as I can and really
understand Japanese culture
and try to get past this.
This is a problem
that I can solve.
And I worked really
hard at those things.
And so I worked really
hard at learning Japanese.
And it's something that
I'm really grateful for,
like having
something that really
drove me to learn Japanese
really well while I was there.
But despite that, I had this
experience multiple times
while I was living
in Japan where--
and my Japanese was getting
better while I was there.
I'd start a conversation
with somebody.
And I'd talk to
them in Japanese.
And they'd listen.
And they'd look at me.
And then when I stopped
talking, they'd then immediately
turn to the Japanese
person standing next to me,
and they'd go like this and say,
look, he can speak Japanese.
[LAUGHTER]
And this happened a few times.
So I'd get used to
trying to ignore it.
And I'd turn back,
and I'd speak to them
some more, like come on,
let's have a conversation.
We can do this.
And they'd listen.
And they'd look.
And they'd turn back and
say, he's really quite good.
It's amazing.
And I felt like just saying,
I'm here, like hello.
I'm a person.
You can talk to me.
And for some people, there
was just like this basic--
I don't know if this
resonates with any of you,
if you feel like you've been
in a situation like this.
But for some people, it was
just impossible to get over
that barrier where they
stopped treating me just
as a stereotype,
as the gaijin, the foreigner,
and started actually
connecting with me as a person.
And this was by no
means universal.
And I had a fabulous
time in Japan.
And the reason that
I had a fabulous time
is because of those
people who looked
past the stereotypes, who looked
past me just being a foreigner,
and talked to me as a
person realized that I came
from a different background, I
had a different set of skills,
and I had a different
set of experiences.
And that was actually part of
the wonderful thing in terms
of friendships and so forth.
We could have conversations
and exchange ideas
that two Japanese
people speaking together
might not be able to
have because we've
got a different mix of
information and background
and so on.
And so that's why I think
it's so important for us,
it's so valuable for us, to
be treated as individuals.
And that goes for everybody.
Right?
I think that all that
everybody in this room
wants is for us to be
valued for who we are.
Like I said, we all have
different backgrounds,
different experiences.
We all have different
skills and abilities.
We all have goals and ambitions.
We're all working in tech.
And we all want to do something
amazing like change the world
through working in tech.
And the right way
for us to do that
is by building an
inclusive environment.
And it's something that's
equally applicable, I think,
to men and women.
If we can understand people
as individuals and the things
that they need, the
right way to understand
who they are and then help them
through their careers, that's
what I think will really build
a truly diverse workforce,
a place where we can all
be happy being ourselves.
So with that, I wanted to
hand the rest of this evening
back over to all of you.
You're all individuals.
And you're all here as
part of a community.
I hope that you've
enjoyed yourself tonight.
I hope you've learned something.
I hope you've had some fun.
And I hope that you
meet somebody new.
I hope you take a chance to
meet somebody new here tonight.
Thank you so much
for coming out.
And it's been a real pleasure
having you here at Google.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]